uh those of you who don't recognize me
I'm David thorburn professor of
literature and director of the
communications Forum my job today is a
very light and delightful one is to
introduce our moderator who will handle
things from there our moderator today is
my friend and longtime colleague Tom
levenson who's a professor in the in the
program of in comparative media studies
and writing he's the winner of the
Walter P kler science documentary film
award he's the winner of Peabody Award
uh uh he he won an Emmy uh from the New
York a New York Chapter Emmy for his
work as a as a filmmaker and he is the
author of a series of distinguished
books in cultural and scientific history
uh history of science uh Newton the
counterfeit and Einstein in Berlin are
two of his uh most recent titles uh it's
a a delight and and and a pleasure to
introduce Tom
levenson
[Applause]
thank yikes thank you very much David um
and thank you all for turning out on you
know in in the holiday season when it's
sometimes difficult to find a moment um
I want to uh just note one thing the
communications Forum which David has
headed for many years is uh is is the
program that made this event possible uh
they've been a an integral element in
thinking about um writing communication
other media and speaking to the public
about important issues for now decades
and and David's been the the major Domo
for I think just about all that time uh
and we're you know I personally am very
grateful to be here under that Banner um
so our two guests I want to get into it
very quickly because we got a lot of
ground to cover uh our two guests today
are probably very well known to you by
by reputation and by line uh James
Fallows Jim Fallows and Corby cummer
both employed by the Atlantic for many
many years uh Jim phow has been National
correspondent of the Atlantic again for
decades written for the magazine since
the the late
1970s uh he's edited the US News and
World Report he has worked as the chief
speech writer to President Jimmy Carter
uh he is the author of 10 books most
recently China airborne and he is one of
the most um consistently excellent
writers of long
thoughtful um on the news but not in the
news of the moment necessar
journalism that we've seen for a long
time and I apologize for that incredibly
poor locution I think you get what I was
trying to say um in addition to China
Airborne Airborne his most recent book
He's written blind into Baghdad 2006
Postcards From Tomorrow Square 2009
amongst his many other books um it is uh
one never wants to sort of name people
by their Partners but uh but Jim's
partner Deborah fallow is uh is his
partner on his current uh blog exercise
of traveling around the country uh has
been the source of much of his own
interesting Reflections on language and
and should be mentioned and I should say
that that one of Jim's uh perhaps not as
frequently acknowledged excellences as
it might be is that he's one of the
leading beer bloggers in the country uh
and I think that's important to mention
on this the 80th anniversary of the
repeal of
prohibition
so Corby cumer
is a senior editor at the Atlantic the
uh the the instigator and leader of the
Atlantic's Food Channel for its it's
great life I wish it were still there
and I'm sure he does too uh he is uh the
winner of several James Beard awards I'm
not sure how many six now six okay it's
it's hard to keep up including given uh
that this is named for one of the people
I regard as one of the Great American
Writers of the 20th century my favorite
one his mfk Fisher award uh for
distinguished writing about food in the
James Beard series uh he's the author of
The Joy of coffee he's written I can't
count how many articles in the Atlantic
and elsewhere he has been the restaurant
critic for New York Magazine he is the
restaurant critic for Boston magazine
and uh for tonight's farago most
importantly he is he is one of the uh
most well regged and uh and sensitive
and skilled editors of long form
journalism uh that are working today and
I should add that Corby is at least
temporarily and I hope for a long time
one of us here at MIT he's advising to
MIT graduate students in their Master's
thesis and next year for those of you
who who are students here next semester
rather uh he's teaching the science
essay class and you have a chance to
learn how to write essays from one of
the the hardcore working editors right
now so sign up don't be stupid with that
let's get the program
started introduction we only want to be
introduced by you okay that we can
arrange that all right so so what we're
going to do tonight um over the next
little while is I'm going to try and get
out of the way as much as possible while
the two men next to me uh speak about a
series of editing encounters that
they've had on major pieces that Jim has
written and Corby has edited or has
worked on if he hasn't edited entirely
um and and we're going to try and draw
out some different themes in what it
takes to do long form Journal ISM at the
level of of quality and expectation that
the Atlantic Monthly uh brings to the
table so um I guess I'd like to start um
asking you Jim about the process that
led to um the work you did on trying to
help us understand the Iraq War
so as you were talking to me earlier I'm
not I'm just going to crib um September
11th happens and it's clear to at least
some people yourself included and some
of your colleagues uh that you know
whatever the Kabuki going on in
Washington may be we're going to be at
war in
Iraq um the Atlantic is a monthly
magazine it has a long lead time how do
you start thinking about covering an
event like that so thanks for that
question thanks for the introduction and
it's really nice to to be here and so
I'll give a couple of of points of
background you know Corby and I have
worked together for now more than 30
years almost every article I've done for
the Atlantic in that time
one or two the the editor of and and
most of the time we worked with Bill
Whitworth who was the editor there for
20 years and we've had a succession of
other great editors since then in this
case in in the fall of 2001 I'd been
living for three years on on the west
coast I was in Seattle for two years in
Berkeley for a year and I moved back to
DC flying in my little plane we dropped
off our son at College up here in Boston
we flew down to DC in our little plane
on September 10th uh 2001 and so the
next morning woke up in in DC and
suddenly there was a news of September
11th the editor of the magazine then was
Michael Kelly whom many of you know of
he was the editor until he was killed in
Iraq as an embedded journalist in the
first two weeks of the invasion but he
when the phone started working again in
in uh in Washington we started talking
about how the magazine could cover
events there and by by a few two or
three months after that Mike Kelly who
was preparing to go into his embedded
journalist role cullin Murphy who' been
the managing editor under Bill Whitworth
and under Mike 2 and was essentially
editing the magazine then and Coring I
we realized that for news that was
changing you know day by day and when we
had our six-month lead time we couldn't
do things other other places could do
what we had to do is figure out what
other people weren't going to get around
to covering and I think it was Cullen
who came up with the idea that we know
you know 10 months ahead of time we know
we're going to war and we know the us is
going to win and so let's start doing
the article people were want to know
after that Invasion happened so I spent
three or four months talking to people
who were experts in Iraq itself and
people who are experts in military
occupations and people who were expert
in how uh you know things went wrong in
in in military occupation so I I
finished by I guess Late July early
August of 2002 this article we decide to
call the 51st state what would the pred
we call it the predictable consequences
of victory in Iraq and then I fed it
into the grinder that consists in a good
sense of Corby and kin then and others
and that so that's how we decided to do
it that one other point here I think the
distinctive skill of being a monthly
magazine editor is being able to imagine
what will be interesting six months from
now that the big newspapers won't have
gotten around to doing and this was
exactly a point I was going to make it
was a preent piece and it's one of our
great pieces
ever uh and it was in not in the context
today I was trying to think were you
still were you yet writing nearly as
frequently for your website then our
website was still in its baby stages it
was in its baby stages and in fact we're
all going to go celebrate the
publication of a book by the woman the
brother the sister of our current editor
Sage tosa who was running the website at
the time but what I was thinking as I
was thinking of the process of what will
people need to know in a few months what
will they need to know into the future
which during the entire time of the
Whitworth tenure we always had to keep
in mind it is what we still have to we
will some of us will be you won't be
there at an all day planning meeting on
Tuesday for mapping out long range what
do we need to be thinking about for the
next year I've been to enough of those
meetings so oh yes yes yes you are you
uh I've done my time you have
no no so in any case it is a hugely
challenging process but now as as I
think back to what the distillation
process was it was the daily news in a
newspaper still it was kind of what the
posts and the times were doing and as
the Ft really emerged as heroic in its
daily coverage but we knew that we had
to think of what will be a monthly piece
that will stand the test of time it
somehow was easier and more aart to
think of that then without the daily
noise of the web and the commentariat
which hardly existed then the daily
constant commentar imagine if the web
had existed then the same volume and
highs and lows in a way it would have
made this exercise more valuable because
I remember that that DC journalism is
so like a you know three-year-old soccer
game where everybody's around the same
ball all the time that then then all of
it was sort of this minute by minute um
plan you know the stuff that was not
looking forward at all so that gave us
the opportunity to do it and maybe that
that immediate centrism would be even
stronger now who knows I I hope somebody
tweeted that that remark about make sure
it gets out there in the world okay and
I should really say a six-year-old
soccer game three-year-olds can't play
soccer very
well and you all have to read Jims
breaking the news which is it's from a
sort of age of Lost Innocence of the
news media that came out in 1996 which
in retrospect looks like you know the
the the the housian era not that you
thought the med media was at all
innocent including this and this was but
for those of you who haven't read it it
was uh the antidote to the kind of in uh
base in baseball media coverage that Jim
so strenuously objected to that was so
self-referential and that is still uh a
detriment of Journalism was just the
kind of long range pieces that we were
doing but somehow it seemed more
distinct and sharply distinct the idea
of a piece that would have long range
value uh as opposed to daily journalism
than it does today I think th those
distinctions have started to bleed a bit
let me let me actually ask you though to
to drive a little deeper specifically
into the into the Iraq situation so we
we um I mean I remember the journalism
of that period very well and there's a
lot of Dishonor there I mean you know
uh real failure to cover some of the the
the presuppositions for the war
um how were you able to
avoid those
pitfalls that is say covering what
the you this isn't really fair but I
actually the first time I ever
encountered your encountered you Jim I'm
sure you you don't recall that encounter
it was at a crimson alumni dinner where
you and Michael Kinsley were talking
during during the Carter Administration
and Kinsley said under some prodding
from a number of people that of course
journalists have to follow what the
President says it was you know why was
the coverage of Reagan as it was was the
question and you said slightly
plaintively I hope I don't do that well
here in in 2001 you had that challenge
and you managed to negotiate that I want
to know how so I I think there were
there was um the Atlantic during bill
witw worth 20 years Bill Woodworth still
very active in in Little Rock Arkansas's
Hometown as a book editor and who we
talk to to frequently he had a he had
come of age journalistically at the New
Yorker when when he was probably in his
late 30s must mid or late 30s he did a
famous piece whose title I forget but it
was an interview of some naive questions
about uh War I think War so this was
during the ramp up to the Vietnam War
and and Bill Whitworth then a young man
went to talk to Eugene rostow not Walt
rostow but the brother Eugene who was I
think the dean that y Law School land or
something was a big big Hawk and Bill
asked him essentially okay suppose we
pull out of Vietnam and was said well
that would be bad they'll say well how
exactly would it be that we lose
credibility well what exactly would that
mean and so that sensibility I think one
factor is that had permeated into all of
us of let's try to get through this uh
whatever are the catchphrases of the
foreign policy cabal or or greater DC
and and and as a side note DC in New
York after 911 attacks had its
understandable trauma and everybody in
New York was sort of radicalized DC just
had a William Randolph Hurst war fever
for which The Washington Post was the
cheerleader and it just was was horrible
and so Bill's sensibility is one thing
also I had done a lot of since my first
work for the Atlantic had been
essentially trying to get an Outsiders
knowledge of the military I did a book
called National Defense early in the
Reagan year saying what's all this money
for and it was mainly based on reporting
with actual soldiers and Marines and and
going around so I had a lot of contacts
in that world and I was asking these
people okay uh we know there's this big
war fever going on what are you going to
do there and and the most interesting
thing I did in reporting this 51st state
piece was going up to the army war
College in Carlile PA flying my little
airplane to the Carlile airport and they
had this whole future of Iraq project
where they mapped out in great detail
what the problems were going to be if
you after you invaded Iraq and how you
could prevent them number one was
looting number two was you shouldn't
disband the Army number three was you
know going down this whole uh trail of
things we actually did so people who
were military professionals they had a
very cleare eyed look of and so you
remember my joy when I came across these
people from the army war college right
but we we should be talking about two
pieces the 51st state and blind into
Baghdad uh because one prospective one
retro right right because blind into
baghad was was talking about all the
mistakes that were were made that could
easily have been foreseen and in fact
were
foreseen uh which Jim went to again the
kind of
longterm piece that seldom happens in
any other form of Journalism besides a
monthly well we'll get to that in we'll
get to that claim in a moment because I
don't think that's true anymore um but
uh again to dive a little deeper into
that process you know you get um what
was the amount of time you took from
from conception to to to final so if we
say that that we thought maybe in
February or March of 2002 that is to say
a year ahead of the war when still it
was in theory an open option again one
other side note on the afternoon of
September 11th I called a guy I knew who
was then an Air Force Colonel who I'd
met you know long long ago and i'
actually ridden into F-15 with this guy
uh long ago and he was then in the Air
Force's planning he said you know we
don't know where this came from but I
can tell you the answer is going to be
in a wreck and so you know 3 hours after
the attack they were were knowing that
so from the answer or the action they
actually thought that the answer what
they were going to do you know he he was
not saying Saddam husin is to blame he
said what's the this is the action the
reaction is going to be Iraq so uh so
from February or March
until early late June so two or three
months of traveling around interviewing
people that was the time of the
reporting and then the nightmare of
writing begins that's that's what I want
to get at you've got a you're still in
June or July mhm uh s or eight months
before the actual
Invasion so you're writing a piece
against an event that's that's right a
very long time away what what did you
have to do and how much did you have to
sort of how much did you find out doing
the piece that you had to then
revisit there
was there was almost nothing that the
people I was quoting projected that
didn't h i mean there were things that
were off in detail but it was was really
they were depressingly preent about what
was going to happen mainly this army war
College survey and also these these
experts on on Iraq itself but it so I
think the trying to remember how it
began something like everybody knows
we're about to invade Iraq and everybody
knows we're going to win or something
like that and the question is what
happens they per if there was some way
to look this up online perhaps yes but
whether it's online or not uh the idea
but that that idea was in advance we are
going to invade and we will own this
place hadn't hadn't Rumsfeld already
said you break it you as was Co and pal
I think that was earlier and maybe it
was it was when he was rationalizing why
they didn't go into Iraq the first time
you know under the first Bush I believe
so so th so this is the um the main
thing I regreted that about that piece
is not more F clearly saying the end I
saying here are all the things that are
going to happen and I should have said
more clearly therefore for God's sake
don't do this but that's but I read I
read I remember and I read that entire
piece as a cautionary these are all the
reasons not to move forward with
military action which was very much in
that bill Whitworth here are all the
terrible irreversible things that will
happen because but we knew it was going
to happen yeah the way you actually
ended that piece is if we can judge from
past Wars the effects we can't imagine
when the fighting begins will prove to
be the ones that matter most this is a
this is a theme for Jim you've said that
in many ways but what was the what was
the
lead the lead was in incredibly subtle
over the or or just sort of you know
soft no no no written at 2 A.M when he
had to yes sort of softly softly trying
I think you were trying to persuade
people rather than tell people persuade
people that they might be wrong rather
than tell people that they were uh it
begins over the past few months I
interviewed several dozen people about
what could be expected in Iraq after
after United States dislodged Saddam
hsein that's not the actual lead there's
something else that's the actual lead U
really I'm I don't write this stuff I
just I just deliver the lines yeah I
don't
huh okay so I was thinking the second
paragraph Was the actual lead any well
so it's saying that that this is going
to happen What can we expect y okay so
yeah the second yeah but and I guess
that lead that I to my horror is the
actual lead that's a showing your
homework kind of lead you know here's
what I've done here's the here are the
facts and but this is this is a this is
a tendency of yours that I don't try
always to erase the tendency is I am not
going to claim that I have come up with
the ideas here I am going to say I've
spoken to many people uh who formed this
General drift and this General current
of thought which I'm going to report to
you and then let us decide together what
we think it's a very collegial and
considerate way of presenting
information which has never been the
columnist's way for example and and I
think in the modern journalistic mode
where we have our daily and hourly blogs
and we have have articles you can have a
range of registers there are things on
which I can say I've thought about this
for a long time and the following is
true you I'm going to tell you America
depends on immigration we have to keep
immigrants coming that is true other
things I can say as a reporter I'm going
to tell you what the range of opinions
are or what the range of opinions is and
so here you know make your draw your own
conclusions okay so two quick things one
is to those of you standing in the back
there are many seats in the front I know
it's terribly intimidating to walk down
and sit in the front but you will be
more comfortable en you'll you'll have
the the joy of a closeup perspective
come keep us company come on down so and
David's about to herd you down so you
have no choice yeah um but the question
I wanted to put uh now to you Corby is
all right so Jim goes off and reports
for three months on a piece that has
real
consequences and then you uh then the
writing process begins and it's very
difficult because for all the reasons
that that you've just been talking about
um what's the first thing you do when
when this first draft manuscript comes
in that I mean you can describe the
state you saw it in as as as Jim turns
in uh that first manuscript well the
first draft never comes in whole that's
true so it it's very hard to as Colin
would say take the temperature of a
piece because it comes in in pieces and
Jims has many patented ways of
presenting articles but the main one is
to submit partial drafts and I I I just
have to lend a discourse a of um a a
young kid I've been helping a lot and I
I'm crazy about got an assignment from
Harpers for a very long piece and he was
a very long long way uh away from being
able to finish it but he had 80% of it
that mean you would consider that done
yes so he had 80% of it ending TK right
exactly patented ending TK is Jim's you
know three most favorite words I was
going to do a a a a slide of just
patented ending TK on the end of his car
letter so a draft doesn't come in in
full length in any case I told explain
what TK means oh to come and there's a
whole uh quaint lingo from types setting
days so that you wouldn't uh a typ
Setter wouldn't mistake something for an
actual word we have the master the most
masterly copy editor of all time Linda
lenthal in our front row our longtime
beloved colleague now at tech review um
and we rely on her to know all these
things TK so uh coming k m i n g lead l
e d you've probably all seen lead
spelled strangely and this was so that
one wouldn't confuse it with an actual
word it was so quaint you know the idea
that people actually knew how words were
spelled
and they would be thinking whether or
not to use it so TK means to come so Jim
will have thought out most of what but
you know the here is one of the main
take-home points of our collaboration
the way you work you have a large body
of information you wish to present
you're very good at organizing and
presenting it um sometimes the structure
changes greatly but not that often it
gets things get all lighted and things
get compressed but we all are able to
tease out the themes that are of most
interest and seemed to be almost
dominating and telling the story
themselves in a way that for the writer
him or herself isn't always obvious
with a large Crush of information and
this is why collaboration between
teacher and student and writer and
editor can be quite as valuable as it is
because um now James Bennett Scott
stasel and I can all um confa confab and
compare notes and in almost every single
case when we do this we have precisely
the same take we've all read it
independently and the same themes leap
out at us
therefore when Jim is writing his
conclusion he has ideas of his own and
we say these are things that are that
seem so important to us and so important
to bring out and these quotations are so
provocative sometimes we'll move up a
quotation it's particularly provocative
we'll discuss where that should fall and
where that should land in the peace for
maximal impact we tend to thing have
things fairly high in the peace even
though we don't want to be UNS subtle
the New Yorker is famous for and I it's
never happened to me so I can't directly
report it taking a really provocative
really sexy quote and making sure it's
2third the way through the piece that's
that's I'm told by New Yorker writers is
one of their patented things you have to
put the really sexy quote twoth thirds
the way through it's to keep you awake
it's right it's to keep you awake or
save the best or we are the New Yorker
and we assume you are going to read this
piece through the end but themes emerge
and also you generally we can encourage
you to be stronger and more emphatic in
your conclusions than you who are a very
careful reporter and allergic to people
who prognosticate and have spous errs of
authority are shy of taking and and so
so everything that Corby says is true
but it's also the case and and also it's
the case that as the writer you think
about these things as time goes on and
so if everything were obvious to you
when you started you wouldn't need to do
all the sort of work till the end but by
the time by the time you finish you hope
that it goes in an completely inevitable
seeming logical train but it's not
inevitable until you figure it out and
also this is where readers
help of course how much Jim uh I would I
mean what I'd like to know is how much
um does it help you when you have
Corby um in effect tell you what you've
written does that enable you to
understand what you're do so there are
two stages I mean the Atlantic has many
many stages of of of editing some of
them become exasperating at various
points but they're all they're all I
can't imagine why you would say that I'm
not not talking about you I mean you
know what I'm talking about uh but but
it's so but I think conceptually from my
point of view there there are two and
maybe two and a half ways in which as
the writer you really rely on this this
organism one is the thought editing as
as Corby is is describing one when I
worked my first magazine job was at the
Washington monthly where Charlie Peters
who some of you encountered who is this
crazy genius type of guy he'd have what
we call the rain dances of telling you
uh how you had to to shape a piece but
that kind of thought editing is crucial
but then there's another kind of of
polishing editing where where over the
years I entirely trust corby's judgment
to spend 20 hours a day and I know what
you're doing the other four making me
look better than I would otherwise and
and that is so so that's a second stage
now we have a a third stage of all this
very very intense factchecking and and
other things which I have a sort of it's
like a German car where the door closes
the right way that you don't notice it
unless it does doesn't work so it's
three different ways in which you rely
on the system to make a good product
okay I'd like now to to not switch gears
but to switch uh Focus to a to a couple
of different pieces uh that Jim and
Corby have worked on um you recently Jim
did um a a profile of of one of my
absolute favorite Californians uh Jerry
Brown and about a year ago I guess a
little more than a year ago you did uh a
piece uh about Barack Obama they're both
ostensibly profiles they're both long
they're very considered uh uh
interrogations of those subjects um but
they are quite different as you read
them and I understand they were quite
different in construction yeah and my
short version of each of them I'll give
say a little more about the Jerry Brown
one first then Corby will have the the
high view is I had really a lot of fun
doing this Jerry Brown piece and but it
was a sort of near near a close call it
was almost off the precipice and and the
short version is it really mattered with
a Jerry Brown piece that at the last
minute I could spend a lot of time with
him and it probably was good on the
Obama piece the last minute I couldn't
spend time with him that probably made
both of them turn out better but also
why don't you give a little color and
texture of what it was like to try to
wait to see if they would uh give you
interviews well with the brown piece so
the backstory here is I'm from sou of
California I view the sort of Arc of
California uh replicating that of the
United States in various ways one is the
the innocent well well the main thing is
that everything that's good and bad
about America on the world stage that is
vibrant all this private activity
incorporating the talent of the world
Etc that is but also having a
dysfunctional government those things
are more true about California you know
California has more sources of
innovation and a worse government than
most most countries do so I I wanted a
way to tell that story America story in
California's time I seen Jerry Brown as
a when he was a young governor and I was
a young person in California I had a
chance to see him as as a a return um
governor and I'd seen him about a year
ago there was a dinner in Washington
where I got to sit next to him just by
chance and really enjoyed talking with
them and then we decided that we needed
more profiles this was a way to write
about governance issues and a way to
write about California too and so I then
started the The Watch to try to get an
appointment with this guy and so first
there was one in DC in February of last
year February of this year February of
this year National governance
Association so I'm supposed to meet him
at 9:00 am in the JW Marriott uh down
town so about quarter to 10 he and his
wife stroll in with with no Entourage
was interesting I talked to them for a
long long time then I was going to go to
California for a follow-up interview I
was there for 10 days in California
waiting nothing happened flew to DC that
night I got a call we'll get back to San
Francisco the next day and I can talk
with you so then I I flow out there and
I had the lead for the lead for the
story which was so I had this come to
California the next day I get into San
Francisco Airport before noon my cell
phone starts ringing and it's Jerry
Brown saying well okay you're in San
Francisco Airport you get your car you
take you know they take the Bay Bridge
to the 605 then take the 110 if you've
seen The Californians on Saturday Night
Live it was Jerry Brown doing the
Californian Rift entirely
unselfconsciously and so I had a nice
lead for the story I spent several days
with him and his wife and it was really
interesting so that turned and I felt as
if thanks to your guidance and Scots and
James I was able to tell the California
story plus this interesting guy can I
can I push you on that just a little bit
I mean the the the rap on profiles is
it's the great man approach to history
which has all the flaws that tolto and
many others have said uh how do you
avoid that either as an editor or as a
writer
conceptually we won't assign a profile
now until there seem to be larger themes
the person is Illustrated it's very
seldom that we would just think that
somebody has such an odd personality
like Donald Trump you know who's so
colorful and strange that why don't we
do that that we leave that to other
magazines it's not particular our
Province most magazines if they're going
to do a story about a subject they they
make it a profile I mean that that is
the sort of the shtick of of most
high-end magazines and our stick is the
reverse actually we do a profile as an
exception rather the rule though we try
to do more of them but but the great man
Theory I think in the case of Jerry
Brown actually was applicable because
you have a large drama of California
going into its problems sort of the
descent from Pat Brown through
Schwarzenegger and and coming back up
but Jerry Brown himself I mean he is
really interesting as a guy I will
attest he's of I've known a lot of
politicians he's the only one I've
enjoyed talking with as opposed to being
talked at by politicians you know Bill
Clinton is really fascinating to be
talked at by but it's a talking at uh
experience so so he's interesting as a
guy and if you think of his background
so he grew up when his father was the
Sun King God of of of California and he
then was was Governor himself in his 30s
and he and then was you know he ran for
president three times and lost he was uh
he was eight years the mayor of Oakland
and now he's back as governor and he's
the only person in California knows
politics and correct me if I'm wrong but
a lot of this was it was really going to
be a profile of California and the
California that you knew when you were
growing up which had endless amounts of
money huge investment in education and
then a completely different
California that Brown the son uh
different from his father and different
from the one he knew when he was first
in politics and as I remember this was
going to be a lot Jim doesn't write
about himself much except on the website
sometimes uh this was going to be a lot
about your view of California and the
two Californians that you knew as well
as brown but then you found Brown
sufficiently interesting so but that was
part of the theoretical underpinning of
it and and there was the what what
became clear when you both saw the the
flatness of the California political
landscape where the term limits had such
an effect that there was a time under
Schwarzenegger where the speaker of the
house was a freshman was a freshman
legislator you know that that's how sort
of raised it was and by contrast you
have Jerry Brown and the image I had it
would be as if Bill Clinton got to come
back to be president again with
everything he learned and Bill Clinton
had been raised by LBJ you know sort of
that sort of steeping and in uh in just
and to see somebody that in Jerry
Brown's case he was very much anti
politics in his 30s and now he just
loves everything about how the political
machine works but in a good way so it
became a defense of politics too I'm so
glad everybody got the Bill Clinton
raised by El by LBJ in a moment I
tormented Jim over that line said what
does this mean just How Deeply do you
want people to consider this analogy but
the answer is not at all it's a laugh
line so thank you for mentioning that
again
anytime so the Barack Obama piece very
different there's a there's just a faint
distant echo of you know Sinatra's got a
cold in it you never yes presid right
yes yes so the idea was this
was trying to think of the timing of
this this came out there was some
horrible Christmas party holiday party
the Atlantic had where we decided that I
had to finish this piece like we're
having one tomorrow night by the way
we're all looking forward to it no it
was a great party
it was horrible for me because the
decision made on the Fly was that
actually this piece had to be for the
next issue so I had like 10 days to
grind a piece out of out of nothing
while we were still waiting for Obama to
say we'd had like a six-month ramp up oh
yes Obama was going to give a big
thoughtful pre-election interview to us
and why not you know we were a good
thoughtful magazine we'd been um more
sympathetic with his ideals than many
others we had run a cover we have run a
cover by Andrew Sullivan while Obama
matters or why Obama now in which we
essentially said this magazine is
backing this guy for president it was ah
had and and there was a there's there's
are various vulgar terms I was I'm going
to use but I I I won't hear in academ
about the way they treated us but I
understand why the Press resents Obama
because they really gave us a hard time
including I was out in California seeing
our kids for Christmas vacation and the
idea I was like a moment's notice to fly
to Hawaii for an interview and then that
you were on standby and including on
Christmas Eve yes and then finally I
said no no dice and we're doing
something else and so but that made for
a better piece because I had to say talk
about the situation of the presidency
now and what you could say why all
presidents fail in certain ways and how
Obama was failing in a different way but
why still so this was a piece that it
had a couple of ideas behind it that you
went into because you had a very
carefully prepared set of questions and
instead of having Obama answer them
however he might answer them essentially
we said Jim you answer them what uh are
the best guesses we can have and what
does history tell us about second terms
and as a result it became the road map
for every other writer to still use in
in in fact the
um the um difficult opening of Obamacare
how can we that euphemistically it was
something that was predicted essentially
in Jim's piece there are disasters in
every second term it is very hard to
overcome them and drive forward one
agenda and you notice that in his radio
address Obama has just said it's going
to be economic disparity that's the rest
of my an economic opportunity and this
is like they've all read Jim's piece and
it's the Playbook it never would have
been that thoughtful that analytic or a
Playbook if you'd had to be respectful
of what he said and and also I mean it
is in in the modern High Velocity uh
news industry if I'd had an interview
with him there would have been a sort of
two-day flurry of whatever he actually
said in that interview which would have
to dominate the piece because there was
this formal bargain that the Press
office was making with at the end which
is yes we might humor you with this
interview if we know it's going to be
the center of the peace and what he
actually says and that is that would
have been it's good that didn't turn out
I was mad at the time especially having
to
that was a real that was a very
unpleasant writing experience as they
all are no no that was particularly
unpleasant because we were holding the
piece and you know literally holding the
presses something that never happens
anymore and then at the very last minute
they were Ned yeah so in your 51st state
piece you spent several months reporting
with people who had insight into the
history of invasions and and and we're
using it expertise uh to drive your
thinking and you quoted them in this
piece you're making judgments about a
second term and I mean it's I read the
piece at at the time but it's been a
while I've just been skimming through it
here um there are very few quotes you
are really distilling your own judgment
and this was in the category of things I
can purport to say ex cathedra and also
with with cor a lot of urging from Corby
saying don't rely on the on the sort of
Journal prop of quoting somebody you
know Professor X from George Mason
University says this you know ju just
say it and this is I'd worked for Jimmy
Carter of uh of fond memory uh you know
back when I was in my my my mid-20s and
had spent a lot of time seeing
Administration struggle and in
preparation while biing my time to see
Obama I've been talking to historians
I've been reading lots of stuff and so
the light Motif was and I I guess the
other drama of actually living half the
time in DC over the of all the years
since Carter is recognizing that the job
of President is literally impossible it
requires a combination of skills no
human being has ever possessed and so
the qu what the what happens in the
first term is seeing the ways in which
this incumbent will fail and to see
whether he or she gets better on the
areas of of inevitable weakness and so
in which ways has Obama failed and yeah
and more than that you talked about the
impossible pressures of the daily stream
of web reports and everything being
tweeted and remarked upon at the time
you made a great point of that
and and the ways in which the the ups
and downs of of conventional wisdom are
so extreme I mean it literally is the
truth you can go look it up that Bill
Clinton's health care plan was very
popular until there was a congression
there was a congressional recent in the
fall of fall of his first year and fall
of
93 and then all Time Magazine and
everything Time Magazine which then
existed and others Publications were
said saying yeah this this Clinton care
look looks looks great and then there
was a Blackhawk Down episode in Somalia
and suddenly there was everything looked
bad for Clinton and that's when popular
wisdom changed and Clinton looked
terribly vulnerable after the midterms
you know that he was he was going to be
a one termer so so going against you
never go wrong betting against
conventional wisdom in
DC so uh another tweet yeah really
um another quick segue and then there
couple things I hope we we get to do
before we open it up for questions but
but I'd really be
curious now um for you to talk about a
couple of of you know these were
profiles they're they're focused on
however however much you you you create
a them thematics around they're focused
on on a single
point um but you've also done a lot of
writing about different
International matters of import and and
sort of uh National Andor historic
Destiny kind kind of
pieces and and those are much more
diffuse in some sense and so we were
talking before this uh about um was it
is America going to hell and China makes
and uh uh the much more recent piece
China makes and the world makes the
world takes you never been to Trenton
you all know the illusion from the
Trenton Bridge right Trenton makes the
world takes I love that my my grand one
of my grandfathers was a Ceramics
manufacturer in Trenton and he was
killed tragically a car crashed when he
was 30 and his company went bankrupt a
year later in the depression but so
Trent makes the world takes always has
resonance in our family okay so yes I
interrupt so well no no one of the
titles I'm proudest of I have to congrat
I had no idea have this familiar
residence of Jims um I I now can't get
Reno's slogan the biggest little city in
the world out of my head because that
for some reason um but you know so um
there's a different kind of sort of EX
Cathedral reasoning and there's a
different repor
problem when you do that kind of piece
so so the great narrative theme of My
Life as a journalist in person is is
that of assessing decline you know whe
whether uh and and one of the points I
made in this America going to hell piece
is from America's founding the
prevailing idea in America has been
imminent decline I think you know John
winrep gave some sermon in 1630 about
the decline of the Massachusetts Bay
Colony and it's been a theme ever since
and and you reminded us that Jeremiah
comes from Jeremiah exactly and there's
a wonderful um uh what's his name sack
van burkowitz wrote a wonderful book who
knows sack Van's parents what were they
thinking of when they named him
wonderful book on the American Jeremiah
tradition and and how it's been uh very
very prominent in our national life and
so in my national life has been very
interesting too and so we lived in Japan
25 years ago very interested in those
things and in China I had what I thought
was a contrarian take I'm urging people
take China seriously but do not be
afraid of China China you would have a
hundred times more problems as XI Jin
ping as you would than you would as
Barack Obama but that was sort of what
we were dealing with this America going
to hell piece where I went to a lot of
academics and historians and other
people and said okay are we going to
hell and they would laugh and I'd say no
seriously are we going to hell and just
trying to chart all the different ways
and the report I gave was number one
we've always thought we're going to hell
which is a useful sort of self
motivating uh narrative for the US
economically actually things are looking
better than they do for most other
countries and they have recently but
number three our government is broken in
a way we probably can't fix because it's
the Constitution and so that's that is a
challenge and can you remember the
conversations leading to this I have a
feeling what I imagine is we're
desperate to think of huge ideas because
we need big ideas on our cover and
whatever you were talking about I think
you said to Scot I wonder if America is
America going to hell so I just moved
back from China been there for three
plus years I was in uh James Bennett's
Office where Scott was I think you were
on the speaker phone said well you know
I really wonder if we're going to hell
and so well he said well that's a story
so we made it into one it was fun it was
sort of a profile of an idea it was also
because you were ready to give a new
view on this country after you had spent
so much time uh talking about a very
different country that I was going to
say on the rise but it's too fastled to
say on the rise and on the
decline but the that phrase you just you
just uh used Jim a profile of an idea is
actually a fairly pregnant one um and I
have to say the the the the the sausage
is being made kind of insight of I say
is America going to hell and it's a
cover story in the Atlantic there's you
know it's like the old cartoon step one
an equation step three equation and
answer what's happening in SE two you
need to work on that a little yes right
and so so the the idea of there's a
slogan our ad department has used over
the years of breaking ideas as opposed
to breaking news we're having breaking
ideas I do think of profile of ideas
because you can think of ideas
journalism as being some kind of thumb
sucker essay writing with the quill pen
and I think what what's different from
what we do we try to have more ideas
than just a normal news magazine but
ideas that you illustrate by showing
what it's like inside a factory or going
out and asking people or this is what
what it's like in a military base or
just trying to have it all the tools you
would use for descriptive investigative
journalism towards some um some idea but
this is very much your particular joy in
reporting and discovering new places for
example factories I love factories jla's
factories and breweries these are two of
his favorite places and if if you read
his American future series which you
should all be doing on the atlantic.com
you'll see he makes a point of going to
factories in many different places but
from there his range of reading and
knowledge allows him to do with a lot of
people who enjoy visiting factories
because it's enjoyable frankly um aren't
aable to do which is discern larger
Trends about what this means for our
country and in terms of it's openness or
closedness it's encouragement of
innovation or not and it's political
future there is a an
intellectual part I have missing from my
brain many of them but there's one that
I can address by by being a reporter
which is I can't really be interested in
something until I've seen it and so
countries where I haven't been I don't
really care about but so I like going
places and seeing things and then
reading about them once I've seen
something I can be interested in it
there's one thing that I'm looking at
the you know um how America can Rise
Again is America going to help piece um
it's actually if you're if you're
looking for it on the web it's how
America can Rise Again is is the title
it was the cover in yes that there was
there was dissent by our business
leaders that we couldn't have a cover
story called is America going to hell uh
we should have but that it's called how
America can I don't remember that cover
line at all yeah well it should have
been the real title is are we going to
hell right um but what's interesting is
there's a lot of of sort of classic
reporting you go two places and you talk
to individuals and you report on what
you see and you tell us what they say um
but obviously that's a piece that that
at least conceptually could rely on in
enormous amount of empirical you know
research that you know
uh data that no amount of anecdotes
would work there are there is evidence
of some of that in the piece but you
know not as much as you might expected
MIT sure and and journalism is not
academics and and journalism I you know
there's many definitions of it but one
one is the best available version of The
Truth by deadline time you know but
there's not a deadline it's not
journalism so you're doing your best in
sort of these serial approximations of
Truth and even monthly magazines have
deadlines as we know and as I always
push just beyond not not even just not
even
just he says lovingly uh so so it's
here's another side note the only thing
I know by having done hundreds of
Atlantic pieces now is that finally it
will work out you know even though it
will be right at the margin finally it
will work out just by having done it so
often and when um so but the point is
you this was a subject I had thought
about so much over decades you know
there was a time back in the early 80s I
spent six months on a big immigration
piece for the Atlantic and Bill
Whitworth was a not a pro-immigrant
ation guy and so he was pushing back
against my bring them in bring them on
conclusion from going to see the
Vietnamese and the Haitians and and and
going to the Border in Yuma and all the
rest so these were things I had been
background processing and sort of
accumulating data on for a long time so
you can you can I mean to paraphrase
what I heard you just say not
necessarily what you said uh you can get
away with reporting a piece that has a
has a substructure of information if
you've if you've got enough you know if
if if you've been at it long enough I
think that that that our magazine we
have a reputation for not publishing
things that are really half-ass you know
that that that people think we will have
applied some some process to this and I
don't I try not to write about stuff
that I just don't know about and so so
there's a there's a diverse but sort of
visible range of things that that I
cover and if I'm not writing big stories
about Brazil and Argentina because I
don't know anything about Brazil and
Argentina but you know Jim's very much
the exception in the way our editing and
writing Works in
that you are always the constant in the
pieces it's your sensibility and your
wide range of knowledge your modesty and
relying on actual reporting and people
you trust to make sense to
to Echo whereas with other we have maybe
no relationships now with writers like
that uh we used to have several but time
money mostly money we don't and with
others we have to think that this idea
is uh a good match with the writer and
that the writer is actually qualified to
report on this and the reporting backs
the idea and although things always work
out with you because the collaboration
and your native reporting and writing
ability will always make it work with
other writers we spend enormous amounts
of time um because of course Jim's not
the only person who's laid on a deadline
and you're not particularly laid on
deadlines other writers uh I can't
believe you said that are light but we
we have to have backup pieces for other
writers because pieces fall apart they
they don't work out or they go back
we're we're running a piece now that was
in the shop for a good 3 months and
often pieces are in the shop for longer
before the idea can match the ambition
and the reporting well just in the
relationship between between the two of
you uh Corby when you when you're
looking at at uh certainly especially
Jim's submissions in their earlier
phases um do you ever find yourself
saying
okay that makes sense but you haven't
made me believe it yet enough how do you
you know how much of a push do you give
Jim and and and and what are the sorts
of things that you find yourself pushing
on well the push will often be to have
less um on the one hand on the other
hand and to condense ideas and to D
bring out themes where you'll say very
modestly that you think one thing and
I'll say uh be very just Hammer that
that's something that I often say you
can't Hammer this enough because Jim's
very modest and things can can leap out
at the reader and if they're
sufficiently strong and it's such a good
quotation that we can all trust that
it's going to LEAP out of the reader in
the New York or two-thirds of the way
down or fairly high up in the story
that's fine but otherwi but other than
that sometimes we need you to say this
is why this is important so often I will
ask himim to be more um emphatic in what
he in what he says and and guiding us as
readers instead of trusting us to be
able to sift through a lot of the
information um and it's not that I it
doesn't matter whether I'm persuaded or
not it matters whether I think Jim is
persuaded or not of what he's thinking
and sometimes you yourself haven't
completely made up your mind about
something and that makes for a less
satisfactory reading experience than if
you have and for example this this Tech
piece we did two months ago or so which
was a very unusual piece 50 greatest
breakthroughs that's about the only
piece I can remember having I can
remember writing sort of to spec we knew
we were going to have this Tech feature
somebody had to write what they used to
call the violin in news magazine
industry to accomm it so I was the guy
to write the violin but but in the
process of interviewing all these people
I the first draft I did was just saying
here's the list and then we discussed it
and saying okay here's the point we
actually want to make about the process
of innovation and why we should assume
it's an open Frontier rather than a
closed Frontier Etc but that's another
piece that as you were describing before
with interviews that came in late a
couple of interviews came in very late
and changed your ideas about what the
guiding things would be for it and then
then you were made to write to space you
had to mention all kinds of things and
touch all kinds of bases it was an
exhausting exercise but once you you
touched all those bases in your usual
masterly way there were themes that came
out that we could and it turned out okay
I didn't think that was ever going to
turn out okay but actually I think
through Collective effort we made it up
to our normal standard right yeah of
course this is a just a remark within
our little crowd here yeah okay well but
it's also a great segue because Corby
you have some visible evidence of what
is involved oh I didn't know that I was
going to be allowed to show these well
we'll show a few them and we'll switch
to our our Linda is going to Linda can
we dim the lights a little please so
similar to what Linda does so what you
need to uh what you need need to um say
is when you can so here very similar
things on the right I say it's a
stronger kicker without so these are
just simple things that editors of some
El came up with that I didn't somebody
come up with that unpleasant flashbacks
line other than me I think somebody
plugged that in but you were right that
it's stronger without it anyway two
things what you're seeing here are the
raw documents of corby's edit of Jim's
Works we're just getting this is a
little bit of a look so if you see track
change and what we have to say about
beloved track change is Jim is one of
the inventors of track change and it was
based on the bill Whitworth editing
system and so you have all worked if
you've worked in a Word document you've
worked on something that makes easy and
possible on a computer what we did at
the Atlantic because Jim actually talk
about your time at Microsoft so so there
was a time um I won't go into all the
backstory but for various reasons I was
spending 6 months on a program design
team at Microsoft when they're putting
out the the release of Word XP and the
the one thing I did that changed history
was to provide the sort of tiebreaking
vote to get rid of clippy you know you
seem to be writing a letter welcome so
this is the backstory there is that Bill
Gates's wife had been the original
guiding Vision uh genius behind clippy
so nobody in house could say this is
stupid so I I was there and I could say
this is stupid you appear to wish to
write a letter
yeah which I'll say for the 50,000th
time and the other was this track
changes feature which existed but in in
a very crude form so I worked with some
some Engineers there to give you the
track changes you now seen so yeah and
you asked us and the balloons on the
right which were not the way I think
comments were shown before it's based on
Bill whitworth's writing with with
circles around them uh and he wrote the
best comments ever why was I still being
made to write things by hand yeah so so
Linda asks why Linda has writing that is
smaller than a like 10o type face and
it's printing and it's perfectly legible
even in a blue pencil and she would
often write more on the right than there
were
printed text on the left of a galley
she's remarkable and she was saying why
couldn't I do this on a machine I don't
know the answer to that
um so this is from the tech piece this
is from the tech piece trying to come up
with large themes so this is this is a
um a a point where I will actually ask
you something thematically because I
objected to um yeah being making borag a
hero do you know know all know Norman
borag father of the Green Revolution was
um we were looking for cuts that time
I'd said that one of the themes of our
list was it wasn't individual
contributions except maybe the Gregorian
calendar but then I thought that we
needed to mention uh what is this so why
have I put this up oh because this is
where I'll say this is the kind of thing
my comment on the right this needs more
of a drum roll this is the kind of thing
where an editor will try to guide the
writer and there's this is not a fault
of the writers it is because Jim spent
so much time thinking about themes and
what else
to emphasize in this piece only when
you've gotten it all down on paper can
you understand how do I want to direct
the reader what's the most important
point to bring out now uh and so this is
where I'll say you know please make much
more of this tell the reader we need to
know about this in in this is the idea
editing which is so indispensable but
it's also the kind of thing that that
we're reporters and writers cannot be
expected to know in a first draft and
know how to do and that's where I think
the editing process can really help with
structure it's where well-edited
magazines of which there are a handful
are so different from the book
publishing industry which just doesn't
have the time do to do this kind of
editing
uh not true in my experience I've had
only brilliant book editors that's well
I I have no I I love my book editors I'm
just saying they don't have the the time
time is the exception when talk about
your book editors it's like nobody talks
about their book editors the way you do
yeah I've had the experience of this
this level of but I mean never mind it's
off the subject yes no it's just
disappointing that it doesn't it's not
prevalent in book editing and we are
lucky that we have the luxury so this is
something that a lot of writers will do
this is this is telling something in
advance that we don't need to know in
order to streamline the story and it's
the kind of thing Jim as a fault is is
gracious and courteous to always uh keep
the reader in mind why am I telling you
this let me explain why I am telling you
this here is why it is going to be
important most writers are much too
egocentric I mean they just or whatever
the word is they don't keep the reader's
interest in mind this is a way but every
so often it's not worth it we just want
to get to the story um however the fault
that preceded this is a much better
fault to have than not to have which is
essentially I know that your time is
valuable here is why I wish to take it
up um so here's another thing I don't
know if the if the comment on the right
is legible is it
um so this is the kind of thing you can
only come up with I think after you've
laid out a series of themes it's also
the idea of the collaboration of how to
help structure piece it's once all of
the themes have been laid out is when
someone else can come uh and talk about
it uh and if you want to talk more about
China makes China takes this and a side
note is that that you know a first draft
of the piece is essentially wrestling
into command all this various stuff and
figuring what 5% of the things you found
out are you going to use and so that
there is a sort of wrestling hurting
cats exercise is is it fair to say that
the the that
statement combined with what corby's
trying to say suggests that the primary
job of this first edit is helping to
think about structure is that what
you're doing structure and point and
evidence and all that well Jim is so
good at structure and so much better
than most writers that it's thinking
about major themes that need to be taken
out and cuts of things like every writer
Jim falls in love with uh people and
characters he meets along the way
sometimes those in fact inform the main
conclusions of the piece and become the
dominating themes sometimes they are
sidelights for example I will may I may
I mention another piece of course we
have a piece that was a joy to work on
by a guy named James summers in our in
our previous issue not not this current
issue about Douglas hoffstead the
founder of um artificial intelligence
and there were many points that he fell
in love with and that led us we a field
and it ran at um a little over half its
original length maybe half its original
length and it's one of the few pieces I
think is much stronger and clearer at
its length and he was a joy to work with
because he he really believed in the
cuts but again you or writers fall in
love with lots of facts that don't need
to appear in the final piece and that's
something that often comes clear only
when someone else is reading it there's
a related point about a famous writer
who you all whose name you would know
but I'm not going to name him or her
this is a person whose main I think
you'll figure out who I'm talking about
who presents information and the space
devoted to it in this person's books is
directly proportionate to how hard it
was to find out this information so
points that are of no intrinsic
importance but this person who you know
um spent a had to work really hard to
find out at this point that will be 10
pages long even though it's it's uh it's
10 lines worth so we'll talk about this
later but it's very it's it's a very
understandable impulse yes okay so at
this point I want to open it up to
questions soon but I I I want you to
spend a little time pulling back from
from the immediate work that the two of
you do together and to talk a little bit
about the the history and future of long
form because um speaking from a from a
science writer's perspective um even
though the issue of actually paying for
this writing is very very hard to figure
out uh the number of venues that are
offering uh smart editing and lots of
room for for thoughtful deep um
thematically based rather than on the
news-based stories Eon Pacific Standard
Nautilus the Atlantic when it chooses to
do science Stories the New Yorker when
it chooses and on and on the the web and
off matter medium and so forth and so on
um and you know more than half of those
I just mentioned are places that popped
up in the last very few years they exist
only on the web um and I I very glad you
mentioned Pacific Standard because it is
I actually edit a lot of their cover
stories on the side and uh it is started
by Mor trinsky uh our former managing
editor right and there's adist with its
New Yorker connection I mean there there
there these venues are are are popping
up and many of them are producing work
that used to be the exclusive province
of the Atlantic and The New Yorker and a
handful of other uh major glossies um
and it seems that despite the
predictions that I recall reading for 20
years now that the internet and you know
cable TV and MTV was going to destroy
our ability to to focus on anything for
more than 140 characters or whatever uh
the reverse or or at least a
Counterpoint seems to be
emerging we each have probably views on
this would you like to offer yours or so
so so I I I will offer mine and corby's
may be different um first I think the
natural situation of Journalism as long
as it has existed has been flux and we
were sort of led into thinking that was
not the case by the sort of artificial
lull of the post-war era but where the
normal condition of Journalism is things
starting and failing and so number one
that this is consistent with the past um
number two I am in most things an
optimist and progressivist and think
that change brings at least as much good
as bad not everything politics is has
its problems and I think that in most
ways the supply of just information
about the world is better now than it's
ever been before richer more varied etc
etc then there are two problems that
those previous points don't address one
is you say paying for it I am
extraordinarily fortunate to have spent
30 plus years as a paid writer for the
Atlantic I don't know how many people
will be able to to do things like that
but um so so the economic model which is
a whole separate topic we can talk about
is to be solved and second the other one
consequence is the public knowledge
problem that in the 50s 60s early 7s
there was a sort
of enforced cism of views there were
only three TV networks there were three
national news magazines now there are
thousands of options and that leads to
some of the chaos and public discourse
we have now but there's more good stuff
being written now than ever before in
history I think Corby and there are more
places to see it what what kind of took
me back was there's there's plenty of
places with smart editing um because I'm
not aware of of play medium and the a
the adist to an extent or Ting the adist
that it'ss everything but I'm not I'm
not aware just CU I don't know what is
the editing policy of a number of these
places that are publishing long form and
how much I know because it happens that
one guy I just edited for a pacific
standard is the managing editor of the
atavist and so I know and I was editing
a a friend's piece of former men you
know kind of mentee on the side he was
being tormented by the guy I was
tormenting as a writer and he's the edit
the out ofice so I know that there are
some Wom web based places that are doing
really superb careful Hands-On editing
but I'm aware of medium doing it only
for a certain number of writers and
otherwise they're just making it look
beautiful but you have no idea whether
it's been through another set of eyes
and hands or not I mean I think that's
true I know Eon edits with some care I
think um I know that as you say medium
has a has a sort of two-tier policy that
that um pieces it pays for pieces it
pays enough for it edits and and there's
a lot of unpaid stuff on me and we have
that in effect of the Atlantic too that
the print magazine is produced to a
level of editing and burnishing that
simply would not be possible for the
website because the website puts out
hundreds of things a day don't we I mean
it must be well dozens of things a day
yeah I mean a whole lot of stuff which
you just could not um machine to the
same level uh to say to put it mildly or
fact check Jim has just made one passing
reference to fact check but and we've
we've glorified as well we should copy
editing and text editing as we do here
and Linda is a master of but fact
checking takes up every bit as much
staff time as anything we've been
talking about now often
more progresses into the night and on
weekends and it's just I'm inspired by
our fact Checkers and it is the
difference one main between print and
web and they're able to
part of the person I've worked with most
often over the years what makes her so
effective is that she's able to put on
this aect of complete literal mindedness
you know that that so nothing will ever
escape her her eye it's like the Robert
hline Fair witness from you know that
that that concept um I will say
factchecking used to be I one of the
problems is that you're you're right
that's in Decline it used to be one of
the uh entryways into serious journalism
I fact checked Lewis Thomas and Steven J
Gould back at the start of my career
Carl Zimmer was a fact Checker and he's
now a prominent writer and so forth I
think a lot of people did that and
that's uh fewer and fewer places have
that um we can keep on telling stories
about things but I there's a wonderful
audience here and I'm hoping you have
some questions I James I just heard uh
coming in that oh excuse me there are
microphones and we are taping this so
can you go to the microphone and say who
you are and those of you who have some
questions start lining up IND either of
the two
microphones hi James um my name is Greg
berer I just heard coming in on my
smartphone that Nelson Mandela just
passed away uh what would you write
about him if anything sort of a great
man particularly as it relates to us and
compare and contrast maybe us and South
Africa sort of social situation that
that's that's um I'm sorry to hear that
news although it's it's not unexpected
you know given the last last two or
three three months and this is a case
where where I probably would choose not
to write anything on on the website
about Nelson Mandela which is the only
way I could do it because the magazine
the next we're working on the March
issue now of the magazine because I
don't feel as if I have any special
standing to to say anything about Nelson
Mandel there so it's I think an Impulse
of conventional journalism that leads
people arise or astray is feeling as if
you have to opine on things and that
that's I think columnist feel like they
have to do that and I respected Nelson
Mandela obviously I I I met him one time
which was was very impressive and
interesting I I you know worked for
Jimmy Carter who was of course involved
him so but but I don't think I have any
I don't think I would have anything to
add to the public discourse whereas if
they're I mean someday Jimmy Carter will
die and when that happens I have a lot
to say about him and then we we'll say
something that that point it would be
respectful and other people he's worked
with so that that's an interesting
question which has helped me focus on
who would would say something about
Mandela on on our side is there anybody
who has standing to speak I think it's a
matter of whether he feels if you have
something more to say then I'm sorry
well what I was the main point I was
going to make without actually naming
the Atlantic is the impulse to not say
anything unless you're actually have
something to say is the opposite of
today's internet impulse and so uh it's
just so r that someone would actually
add that and I hope that I don't think
we're going to have personal reminisence
there's somebody I can think of somebody
who is a perfect example of the young
self-named Authority who now no longer
works in the Atlantic who will say
something authoritative and magisterial
this person already has and this yeah
and we will all look a Gog like you know
you were born yesterday but um but but
it's just a question of and it's not old
people resenting young people it's talk
about what you know and you're qualified
to talk about and you're able to say
something about there's one technical
note though because you have this
connected to the internet I saw our
yellow Banner we have designed a yellow
Banner for breaking news and I don't
think that I've ever seen it it's a
feature of our web redesign I'm I'm
biting my tongue dud bite your tongue I
when I first saw the when I first saw
the mockups for the new website I said
as gently as I could is that going to be
on every home screen and they said no
only for important breaking news for the
latest breaking news and in fact there
it is and it's the first time I'm sure
it's not the first time we've used it
but it's the first time I ever called so
so a the Atlantic the Atlantic is a
business success now because it's as a
156 year old publication because it has
continued to evolve so we have our print
magazine which is very strong this last
issue is I was reading on the way here
is really good
we have our events business which is a
lot of our our work but we have our
website which has a gigantic number of
readers around the world and part of the
way you do that is by having it it's a
it's a news site among everything I mean
it has a whole range of stuff just for
the record Natasha Joseph has already
put up something on your website uh
called Nelson Mandela's death in South
Africa's next great struggle well
there's someone who is has standing to
speak um and I if if tanassi has
anything say about what Mandela meant to
him as a youth when he was a youth um
you know tanasi would never take the
pose of I can speak for anyone but
myself he will only speak for himself
and that's part of I gather the the
course on voice he's teaching he will
post if he has something he feels he can
add and
say so Phil so um James and Corby you've
had a fantastic three decade plus
relationship as writer and editor um but
that is exceedingly rare doesn't happen
today what advice would you have for
writers and editors today all who aren't
going to have that experience one thing
I would say is I know I treasure the
relationship with both writers and
editors so much that I I now will keep
up and somehow manage to insert myself
into editing writers I've had
particularly fruitful collaborations
with who don't happen to be writing for
the Atlantic and sometimes they can
arrange for me to get paid but they will
just there are certain writers I love so
much they will show me what they're
doing no matter who it's for or where if
you have someone you really like working
with who's helped you beg that person to
look so many times it's one's spouse you
know one's spouse could be the first
reader but in any case once you were
fortunate enough to encounter a good
editor or a publication somebody I used
on the Food Channel a section of the
website that indeed I miss every day
every hour um worked once as a writer at
a local newspaper in Montana and his
editor lost his job and started doing
other things but they kept up this
relationship and the writer paid a
portion of what he makes on the internet
for his food pieces which are very
thoughtful food pieces he won't let a
piece go up without showing it to that
editor he happened to have worked with
and forged a good relationship with and
I'll say I never expected to have this
longterm a situation in the Atlantic I
worked first first for the Washington
monthly the day after I signed on with
the Washington monthly it declared
bankruptcy uh and it still is going I
worked for Texas monthly for a while and
that that was a you know very up and
down operation so I feel very fortunate
but I think again the natural condition
is as Corby says to have unstable
business alliances and you try to have
these personal relationships that that
endure hi Philip from MIT Salone um you
guys have mastered the written word the
Atlantic long form journalism and uh I'm
wondering now with uh the emergence of
multimedia video um one whether the
Atlantic would consider going um more in
that direction as a sour of potential
long forign journalism and two if you
would have any advice about how to bring
the same level of editorial quality that
you've produced in the in written texts
um to more interactive or multimedia
journalism
long we each have experience in this too
so so I have done some video work over
the years I did a series a long time ago
for PBS on on on Asia and and I also
have a New York Emy for documentary work
so we share that that that wonderful
that wonderful Niche Niche achievement
but I think there's a I think the r the
leap from from printed work whether
short or long to video is a bigger leap
than from printed work to audio I've
done radio work for decades and I think
that that's a very natural transition
for people to make from from writing to
to broadcast to audio broadcast there's
so much more stuff involved in video
presentations I do think of it as a
distinct skill but the Atlantic has a
very good um video team that we're
putting a lot of resources into now and
and so I think we recognize that you
have to reach people in all different
ways you can so I I I think this is if I
were starting again you know two
generations earlier I would want to have
better video skills too well indeed it's
where we're putting a lot of money and
and hires and we had barely one person
and now we have three full-time people
on video and to an extent they produce
and cut stuff but it's also in their
sense creative aggregation it has to do
a lot with finding things they think are
worth bringing to readers attentions and
editing them well as well as producing
original stuff but it's really expensive
and I think it's another discipline yeah
the um I had conversation some time ago
with with tech reviews people when they
were ramping up video and the point I
tried to make to them is that reporters
and writers are really good at difficult
tasks and if you ask them to do um video
as well you know bring along a camera
stick it on a tripod record their
interview do all that sort of stuff
you're asking them both to do more for
the same amount of time or money or
whatever but more importantly you're
asking them to expand out of a skill set
and that you will
as it's it's much more naturally
productive if you really want to build a
multimedia capacity in a media
organization this this is my view but I
hold it very strongly therefore it must
be true
um is great motto it's it's it makes
much more sense to to get people who are
really good in the SE in the different
media and form them into teams when you
want them to produce pieces that have
elements of the different media than it
is to expect people to multiply skills
in what in each case are you know genres
media's crafts that take a lifetime be
to become excellent
at and just if I can p there for a
second I agree with that but I do think
that writing and radio broadcasting
kills are more likely to coincide in the
same person as opposed to video which I
view as a different different thing I
think that's yeah hi I guess it's my
turn um my name is Melissa Ley and I'd
like to ask a question that would call
on your um time spent in China and
looking there today I know it's not
necessarily a long form question but in
order to do long form you actually need
journalists to be there to observe and
to see what's happening and when we look
at the situation today in China I'd like
your thoughts on what's happening with
the VISA situation with both the New
York Times and Bloomberg looking like at
this point they may not have any of
their reporters have their visas renewed
by that uh government so the way that
you look at China in terms of whether
you a think they're calling a bluff you
call a bluff and in the end they'll give
the Visas or what you think is in play
at this moment with this kind of
censorship that seems this is a serious
and bad situation in my view and a sort
a couple of big background points one is
most people I know and trust in China I
was there like four or five days ago I
came back relatively recently they
believe that she this is a can I just
tell a typical gym story we were
together at an Atlantic event where we
were both moderating panels and we were
also we had the rare Joy of sitting side
by side and going through galys and
editing them together it's a joy and
then I said since this was the first of
two days of this event I said so well I
see you tomorrow at at the event and
we'll finish up any questions and Jim
said oh no but I'll explain later so an
email arrived 11:45 p.m. a very normal
time for Jim to send an email and it
said I'm I'm going to China tomorrow
just for a few days so and it was yes so
I was in China for about a week talking
to to various um party officials there
so I think that in terms of economic
reforms I think that the Xi Jinping
Leach Chang team actually does intend to
try to deal with some of the the
economic imbalances but it does seem as
if this is coinciding with a political
either steady state or Crackdown both
domestically and internationally uh the
situation on journalist visas in my view
so that's one one background point and
that's you know often the dong Xiao ping
era was sort of the same way that
domestic control in order to have some
liberalization uh second point is often
the explanation for things in China as
you probably know seems to be chaos as
opposed to Central master planning main
illustration would be seven years ago
when they had the anti-satellite weapon
test which was extremely disruptive
internationally there was debris in the
satellite paths worldwide people's
Liberation Army Air Force sent this
thing off still nobody knows where the
order for that came from was it was it
hentau was it somebody in the pla you
know it's just I think that lack of
coordination is a way as big a problem
as uh as as Central coordination so I
don't know the extent to which this or
the air defense zone are are our top
down orders but it's a real thing and so
I got the visa for the trip corby's
talking about about an hour before I
would either go or not get on the
airplane and I got a single entry 10day
visa and this is uh which just was uh
how it is the people in the the
Bloomberg case is different from the New
York Times where there's there's a whole
case of whether Bloomberg is is uh
censoring itself New York Times They
simply won't give visas or renew the
visas for anybody there and I think that
Biden talked about this this last week
my point is this is a really stupid
thing for China to do because by far the
best soft power initiative they could
have would be just let people in because
my view at least has always been there's
a lot of terrible stuff in China but
there's always incrementally more good
stuff and so if you had really thorough
coverage it would be more positive than
negative but you guarantee negative
coverage with this sort of clamp down
and so I think it's it's it's bad and I
don't I think they'll finally let
somebody in there but it's a it's a bad
situation hi I'm Cooper I'm a sophomore
at TS you talked about how a piece takes
something like three or more months
actually workshop and put out the
process um through thought and text
editing I was wondering if you in your
process at what point do you feel like
you start developing these larger Trend
ideas that allow it to be versus the
online version is there a typical
process is it usually in reporting
versus um the editing
version that's a a great question and
tough with my was my mother's Alma M so
I always feel a a tough uh connection um
so I I think that I'm going to use an
analogy of foreign travel for for the
the structure of a piece it seems to me
when you travel someplace for reporting
or anything else there's a set of sort
of questions or expectations you have to
have that you're going to say I want to
find out about X Y and Z and you find
out about out about those but then there
always the things you didn't know you
were looking for until you got there it
matter to but you have to have the
questions to begin with and then levv
them with what you learned so too with
the structure of a piece you start out
with a question you want to answer and
then I every every single day when doing
reporting a reading I'm sort of testing
hypotheses and the nightmarish moment
when you have to actually write it is
when you say okay now I have to start
figuring out what what I what I think
but many times um authors who you and
tanassi maintain very active daily
websites and often those web entries
will be little rehearsals for and little
Snippets toward a longer piece and in
tanahashi's case I'll
no knowing that he is working on a a
longer uh form themed piece I will write
him and say essentially do you think you
could knock it off because this is
coming so close to the main points that
you're you're going too far into the
rehearsal territory but that is it's
often a very useful way if you maintain
your own website to come up with
reporting they're like they're like
exercises to get your yourself into the
larger theme um and so it's not wasted
time and there are some ideas that
you've been thinking about um I won't
name them because they're going to turn
into pieces I hope but they've been on
our books for almost two years now right
and there's there's a piece that that
we're planning as a giant big deal story
nine months from now which I'm very
religiously not going to do anything on
the website about even though I'm going
to be traveling around doing reporting
for this and I'll be sort of working I
have a set of hypo IES for that but then
we'll we have even a sort of cover line
but then I'll see what how it actually
looks when I travel around right and you
thought of that piece for came up with
thata a long time ago I just haven't
done
it hi I'm Carolina Donovan I'm wrer than
even journalis of lab um and I wanted to
go back to the Obama thing for a second
I was wondering if you think that his
relationship with the Press is is based
more on a personality issue and the
personality of people that work for him
or if there is a really a substantial
element of technology in there and
accessibility that that he has to to
voters or whatever you want to call them
can I just say you did an exag Jesus on
Obama's personality and I think it was
it it happened to me in the moment when
you were remembering gee he didn't see
me when he promised he was going to I
think it's in that very piece but I'll
let him answer that and it's worth
rereading that explanation of his
personality so I I think that that there
is a technological Factor as you say
it's there's been this big flap over
White House Press photos I don't really
take that very seriously because the
supposed golden age that the Press is
trying to recreate is having 500 people
taking the same photo and I don't think
there's any real value added to to that
it's always been very behind the scenes
photos have always been for Logistics
reason you know confined to somebody
who's in the White House Press so there
are technological reasons why the White
House has different ways of getting its
message across but that's always been a
theme there was that favorite famous
case in the early Reagan years where I
think it was Lesley stall did some harsh
interview with Reagan and Mike baver who
was then his PR gay said yeah yeah yeah
you were all criticizing Reagan but who
cares the picture was of this big
smiling handsome guy that's only anybody
remember so I think the technology has
been of each era I think in Obama's case
it's
the every politician ends up hating the
press and even if they like individuals
they end up hating the press as a
collectivity especially uh presidents
because any president thinks I spend all
my day making these impossible decisions
and
you're concentrating on this trivial
crap that's what every single regardless
of party that's what ex-presidents talk
about when they get together how much
they hate the Press because they think
the Press is is packm minded trivia
minded etc etc and the good ones don't
let that show you know they find ways to
seem Charming to to to the Press I I I
think that that Obama has that
constitutional small C
constitutional disdain for the pack
journalism of the White House Press
combined with his intellectual sense of
being smarter than they are and he is a
very smart guy in my my judgment but who
probably is prideful in his intelligence
and and
recognizes recognizes how smart he is
and may may not fully appreciate all the
some of the limits of of that and so I
think that that and finally the people
around him those he trusts are not in
general experienced in the National
media don't nationally pal around with
them so I think it's all these forces
that make uh the natural reaction of
that Administration being who needs
needs these Jokers we know they're going
to have John McCain on the Sunday talk
shows every single week why should we
play into this this stupid game so I
think that's that may be um that may be
what's going on so well actually just to
push you a little further on that um
so the you know certain aspects of that
assessment of Obama are very negative
but there's an open question as to
whether or not he or any president has
been correct in the degree to which they
can bypass or or or or without
consequence stain the
Press
uh let's recall that I worked for Jimmy
Carter who who who who struggles I think
point out the fact that finally it's
huge objective forces that determine
whether or not presidents are seen as
successful or or or or failures we view
Jimmy Carter as a failure now because he
was defeated for for re-election one of
the big themes of my Obama piece is that
it's really important to try to assess
presidents at the end of their first ter
term because after they're either
reelected or beaten everything about
their first four years we view in a
different way there's no way to view the
first four years George HW Bush we can't
view him as anything other than a
failure because he was was beaten even
though very successful in many his ways
same same with Carter um so I think that
that presidents have ways to get their
message out but finally it's the larger
trends of War and Peace of jobs of
inflation when Carter ran for reelection
the who remembers what the prime
interest rate was when Carter ran for
re-election 20 20% prime interest rate
he was challenged by Teddy Kennedy in
the primaries who wouldn't shake his
hand at the convention we had the
hostage disaster we had all those things
and still a week a week before the
election he was within about a point or
two of Reagan in the polls he run
against Ronald Reagan so it was um so so
it was still even despite all those
large forces Carter was able to you know
almost eek it
out and what one thing I I that makes me
so proud of the Obama piece was that the
idea of the difficulties and first terms
only coming uh always being judged by
the results of a second term whether
someone wins or loses was just going to
be one premise of the piece but it
became almost half of the Obama piece
and it's still a definitive piece about
how we view presidents and which terms
matter and the pitfalls are first and
second it's such a lasting piece and
because he didn't see and and and thank
thank you for that and just one one
thing to add I mentioned earlier a sort
of a throwaway line that every pre that
nobody can be a su a really successful
president because there's so many
different impossible things to do you
have to be a good uh speaker like Reagan
to Big audiences which Carter was not
you have to be a good sort of
extemporaneous speaker you have to have
good judgment and temperament and I
think I would rank Obama very high on
those two categories of judgment and
temperament I'd put him quite High um
George W George W bush who got became a
much better speaker I I VI think his his
judgment was uh you know that that is
was his his great weakness and that
mattered more than the things which are
problems with
Obama Seth um Seth man uh MIT um in in
you're talking about your Obama story
and also uh waiting an hour before you
were going to China wondering if you
were going to get the visa um it it
reminded me of how often I find
journalism to be sort of demeaning
because I'm begging people to spend time
with me and is to
me well and so as as someone who has
actually worked in the real world and
not just as a journalist um how do you
deal with that and is that something
that you grapple with so one answer is
journalism is by far the best job that
exists by far uh it's the most
interesting way you can spend your life
you know you have you can have the
equivalent of 50 people's different life
experiences in your own life experience
you can be in a coal mine in China and
the next month that person in the coal
mine is still there and you're you're
someplace else you can see all all these
different things you have a chance to to
sort of share your views of the world I
can give you a whole speech on why this
is is
so so satisfying a way to live despite
its ups and downs think the
builtin demeaning factors of being a
journalist that's one of the good things
about this this line of work and and
when people get out of that and they
start thinking themselves as pubas and
not reporters and pundits and all that
uh that is a that is a a bad sign
intellectually here's what I like about
the process of being a journalist when
you're interviewing people you're always
structurally in the position of talking
to people who know more about something
than you do so you're always in the the
sort of ignorant position eventually you
then tell it about it to people who know
less than you do you're you're the
middleman but I I really value the
ritual need to go see people who know
more about something than you do and so
you learn more about it and it it sort
of keeps you it's one buffer against the
big head which uh you you get otherwise
remember when I was um when I was in
college when I was working on the
Crimson uh Harrison Solsbury who was
then
a venerated um venerated New York Times
Reporter probably 20 years younger than
I am now but he seemed like you know
this this this ancient figure he' just
been to North Vietnam and he came to the
to talk to the reporters in the Crimson
he said one great thing about being a
reporter is
that most people who were reporters were
temperamentally introverts and shy and
they welcomed the structural need to go
out and see the world learn about things
certainly true of me and most people I
know who are reporters are introverted
and shy and they like being in a job
which forces them to go out and uh and
be exposed
so so are you you are not an
introvert um I agree with everything Jim
said about the joy of learning from
other people but I would add and extend
it to the enormous pleasure and
satisfaction of being an editor because
you are exposed to so many people's
finer Minds than your own who have
thought very deeply about subjects that
would never occur to you to research and
you're able to help them in a certain
way that's kind of like Dr patian but
really you're learning so much from them
as teachers learn from
students Pam hi Catherine gine a
freelance science writer and have about
15 years um and my question is in
regards to the economic model and
listening to the the wonderful
experiences um the Jim has flying all
over the world and being supported
financially to do so and for his amazing
work and learning and then living the
kind of the reality of of freelance
journalism today um and and knowing that
there is a two-tier system at a lot of
magazines and you guys referred to that
too at the Atlantic that the print
magazine versus online um content and I
know several people who work for the
Atlantic and are published online and
are not paid by the online presence um
and are told we're sorry we just can't
afford it and they they're really doing
great stuff they're young um journalists
they're trying to get a toe in the field
and they don't see other places who are
willing to pay them for their work they
go to the Atlantic because of the
reputation of the magazine and and they
work for free um and I would just love
to figure out and hear what you guys
have to say about how we're going to
close that that gap between the two-tier
system because I imagine a lot of folks
in this room would love to be in your
shoes one day and so again I I this is a
very serious question I should clarify
something about my own situation I feel
extremely lucky to have had the job I
have with the Atlantic I am paid much
better than I expected to be when I got
into this business for the bankrupt
Washington monthly almost none um in the
years I was living in China The
Atlantics paid zero of my travel
expenses was there it was always just
finding some other way to pay things and
I think in the typical Year my travel
budget for the Atlantic apart from
events is maybe $1,000 maybe $2,000 man
it's always just a matter of catching
some way to this was a there was some
Exchange program that was taking this
trip to to China so I got ticket to go
to China so so it is the consciousness
of I think there are Publications which
had the image of sending people with
with fancy cars every place we've run a
really barebones model all the way along
even though I'm I feel very lucky to to
have a job the talk about paper word
count yes and so I just wanted to give a
realistic image of how the actual
magazine Works um
the there has always
been journalism has always been like
both sports or entertainment and there's
been a supply demand imbalance of people
who wanted to get into it and so there's
always been the period of self-
exploitation for people who want to get
in and that was what uh when I I spent a
couple of years as a freelancer when I
was living in Texas and just you know on
basically no money and that that this
the web model is the modern incarnation
of that and so I think the the we need
to there
are 20 different experiments going on
now what's going to be the new model for
paying people to have an Institutional
professional journalism core if we knew
what the answer was going to to be it
would already be be in place um
journalism schools will be part of it
they'll become practice places I think
the philanthropist model Omi Dr may be
some uh some some bell weather here
there'll be some new model but the web
model we have now is not entirely
different from what was the case 40
years ago when I was starting doing this
and there were alt weeklys where you get
paid $10 for writing something so so it
is getting in has always been a sort of
self- exploitative way and try to do you
hope there's a model after that to pay
people after they get in we hope but
what you really have to hope is there
are any places left that will pay people
to get on a plane and fly and we'll pay
any travel
expenses so I believe you were l in the
black sweater you were next I
thinkon you um I'm just wondering how
you know if it's a magazine article or a
book and is if very tug of war between
you about which way you should go with
something of a Blog piece and that
magazine there's don't publish books but
we do books so to to my mind there
are you should only do a book if you
feel you can't not do it because books
are so discouraging and hard to do and
there are too many of them published
anyway and there are too many books that
actually should have been op ads there
should have been magazine articles so I
only do it if I feel that I can't not
not write it um and I guess the a blog
post versus an article it's whether for
an Atlantic article we know it has to be
something that 6 months from now will
still be viable and there's something
more you can bring by by reporting it
but I have to say something else about
canot do a book books are still I think
a more viable business model than trying
to make living as a magazine writer and
if you're able
to price out of book advance so at least
it will pay your research expenses
because it's very hard ever to get a
book Advance it would pay living
expenses while you're writing the book
but generally the best you can do is
something that will cover the cost to
research and write it that can be more
than a magazine or websites that pay
nothing would pay
you what is there an answer you were
looking for that we have not given no I
just want it sort of um organically like
how do you know an idea is big enough to
be a book um versus just an article and
again for for me as I think of the books
I've done it's because I felt that this
is there's
something I really have the bit in my
teeth and I have to make this case at at
some length and it's not because a
magazine article even very long ones in
the Atlantic there's a finiteness to
them you know sort of the scale of ideas
you can get to in a magazine article and
the amount of stuff he'll be able to
include or not and so for me personally
it's I feel I've had just occasionally
the sense this is something I have to
write as a book and so I'm going to do
that now I will also say that for I was
say occasional means 10 times in Jim's
career with everything else he's written
which is formidable um but I just wanted
to throw in one more complication which
is uh you know the Atlantic now
publishes ebooks like many other places
uh and the first one they published
actually just to to put in a little
promotion for something MIT does was by
our former MIT science writing graduate
student Amanda Martinez um who wrote a
really wonderful piece that didn't fit
either as a fulllength book it wasn't
quite that scale and it wasn't just a
magazine piece either it was a 20,000
word or so piece on this really
intriguing attempt to rid islands of
invasive species um and that was
published as a distinct ebook by the
Atlantic I don't know how successful was
very it was one of the first one of the
first okay mistaken there I'm sorry um
and so one of the things that you know I
am thinking about and Seth thinks about
many of the writers in the room I'm sure
thinking about is what happens when you
have a piece that is sort of in that
middle ground which we now can publish
or at least think about publishing in
ways that didn't exist five years ago
Kindle singles no Kindle singles uh Ted
books um adist runs those lengths I mean
there there's this this sort of ebook
Book E single you know 10 to 25,000 word
sort of length uh is is is a is a sort
of genre that didn't really exist except
as you know the rare John MC forpart New
Yorker p and there's still editing
involved with it I have we have huge
hopes for that so let's just hold it up
as a model of enormous
hope and I'll say also just on the The
Book theme my wife wrote a wonder she's
written a couple couple books she her
most recent wonderful book is called
Dreaming in Chinese she's a Linguistics
person it's what you learn about China
by learning Chinese language and this
came to her when we were living in China
and she just felt as if there was so
much she was seeing about the
intersection between Chinese language
and Chinese life that it would really
required a book to and it's one of those
books that is informed by the love of
Discovery when you move someplace and
this is just rain of new information
it's hailing at you every day and this
was her way of making sense of it that
love of discovering new things it's made
it a handbook for many people who just
were moving to China yeah which is
another way of saying that books Force
themselves upon you um we have time for
two questions if the questions and
answers are quick so those two yeah
those two people and that'll that'll
close out the evening try to be quick
I'm I'm lakmi and my question was
related to the freelance question
earlier um is long form journalism given
the amount of time you sort of uh
brainstorm particular idea is it
essentially institutionally located I
mean is there a space for people say who
are out of Academy academic job market
is not that bright right now and or they
want to do something different they want
to do journalism but how do you see the
conjunction between Academia freelancing
and so your question is is it
institutionally located I do think that
certain forms of Journalism require
strong institutions I think it's very
important that the New York Times in
particular survives because there's a
kind of reparatory
depth that it has and National Public
Radio also and I think that that it's I
think that
that longform magazine style journalism
will probably continue to have a variety
of homes there was a time 25 years ago
when there were more people like me who
had jobs as as magazine writers I think
probably more of them will have their
day job in the academy and in companies
and and whatever but so but they do
require some sort of institutional base
to to and then the institutional editing
structure is is
indispensable right it's the editing
that I would have questions in that
because AC because Academia and
journalism are now much more intertwined
they ever were many of our best best and
most substantive pieces on our website
are really funded by the academy and
they're they're by teachers who know how
to write and really the website would
not have substance without the academy
and it's just producing a lot of good
writers and
writing um I I just want to clarify my
question again I think um is it possible
for a freelance for example to actually
think about being participating in a
long form idea within Atlantic uh yes if
you um we have a number of freelance
writers who who write for us a cam for
example you know the people who are
independent writers it's a matter of as
it always has been in journalism sort of
covering the rent you know if there's a
way that you can can have a income to
tide you over while you're working on it
certainly people who are not staff
writers for the magazine do a lot of our
our important pieces every every every
copy of the magazine has a long form
article that was written by a freelancer
who may never have been in the Atlantic
that sounds wonderfully helpful and that
we're enormously encouraging we have
this huge like 99 to1 rejection rate of
ideas to get those but of course we're
always asking for ideas we just have
this huge bar that we don't want to have
because we have such a tiny amount of
space per year to put it in it's no way
to make a
living stud um I'll ask my question and
then I'll just frame it a little bit um
so my question is 30-year career you
mentioned and interested to know if over
the course of that career and and the
technological changes that that you've
been experiencing if the role of
reporting has changed the role of the
reporter and let me explain that a
little bit um one of the things I've
been writing about recently is the
history of the role of the reporter in
journalism and um starting in the late
19th century reporters became very
Central of course to making news and
initially I would say that at least in
the United States there was this sort of
heroic view that reporters brought
people were fond of calling reporters
modern nights um and you know then you
could move into ideas about
investigative journalism starting around
the turn of the 20th century and then
moving from there into ideas about the
view from nowhere distan objective
so-called reporting um and you could tie
all those changes to technological
changes I think so I'm interested to
know what what you've seen in your
experience is the role of the reporter
changing changing now and and and would
you relate that if it is to digital
media well let me say one thing about
about our our website we have the most
enormously talented young people who
produce an enormous amount of stuff a
day but they don't have time to go out
and do a lot of reporting they have time
to email with people which is the way
most reporting is done as opposed to
telephone often to telephone people but
for a lot of the very rich color and
texture that we have all over the
website that comes from people who are
not employed by us or employed by any
particular media outlet that that's a
result of reporting they've done for
some other Walk of Life that they're in
or some other project that they're doing
and they found something incredibly
sharp and Vivid that we could use so the
actual role of the reporter it's there
are so few newspapers that are actually
Fielding reporters and saying go out and
find
this but have you
Des so uh yes I try to call myself a
reporter as opposed to a journalist
because a journalist sounds sort of like
uh I I I love Act of of reporting I hate
writing but I love reporting um the of
course the role is changing because of
Technology because it always is at every
moment and I think the there's a a
whatever is the technological vacuum of
a given moment is what a reporter fills
with with his or her presence so for
example when TV when radio first became
prominent you would have these voice is
the CBS you know team from Europe and
and moo during the Blitz and things like
that where there was a that was the
first time people could really hear real
person you would know better than I but
it it seems to me like the first time
people could hear real personalities
when TV first became uh preminent you
would have these familiar figures who
are showing you things see you hadn't
seen otherwise now I think the vacuum
that professional reporters can play is
for when there's breaking news say from
Egypt over the last year wherever you
have a richer array of information than
ever before because there's real- time
YouTube amateur video there's experts
from Academia who can sort of uh
contribute on blogs and professional
reporters would apply their respective
skill which is saying okay here are the
actual facts going on here we know this
many people were killed here's what the
foreign Ministry says and that becomes
their distinctive role the Atlantic in a
way has had a consistent Voice through
different times of Technology because
we've always known we couldn't compete
with the actual news it had to be sort
of the informed clear voiced uh not
expert but Observer so sort of the the
the somebody a step up from just the UPI
reporter but he's still using
reportorial skills to say here's what we
can think about Burma um we often a side
note for the Golden Age of the Atlantic
in the mid-60s there was a 70 page
special supplement on Burma I think
wither Burma wither Burma you always
call it wither Burma so so I think that
yes role is always changing and whatever
the technology of the time sort of
leaves out is the vacuum that a
journalist the professional journalist
can then enter I would
say thinking wither burm I want to cue
uh Bing Crosby singing Road to Morocco
but that's anyway that that I think
brings us to the hour thank you all for
for being here can you please thank our
speakers